welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for a presentation titled
the role of serum biomarkers in
estimating the risk of malignancy
and an adnexal mass ca125
and beyond it is my pleasure to
introduce to you
dr kevin holcomb dr holcomb is an
associate professor of clinical
obstetrics
and gynecology at the wheel cornell
medical college
where he also serves as the vice
chairman of gynecology
director of gynecologic oncology
and the associate dean of admissions for
a complete biography on dr holcomb
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them in the q
a box our speaker will address your
questions following this presentation
please join me in welcoming dr kevin
holcomb
i will now turn the presentation over to
him
good morning or good afternoon depending
on where you are um
it's my pleasure to offer this
presentation this morning
as you heard i'm going to be speaking
about the role of serum biomarkers and
estimating the risk of malignancy and
women who present with an adnexal mass
and
as any of the ob gyns in the office in
the uh audience would know
that story really has to start with ca
125 the
the most commonly used serum biomarker
for ovarian cancer
but i enjoyed talking about medical
history and
i've had the opportunity to learn the
story of the development of ca125 from
one of my mentors
so i'd like to start actually one step
beyond behind with the uh the
development and discovery of say 125
because i think it's an interesting
story
it also gives you some idea of the
limitations of ca125
and why we need more accurate uh
predictors
of cancer in this situation here are my
disclosures
um the ibc support for this program is
provided by
abbott the information presented is
based on the speaker's interpretation
the evidence
i also receive research support from
fuji regular diagnostics
and i'm a consultant for johnson and
johnson
uh as i mentioned i know the story of
the development of ca 125
because one of my mentors was a
co-inventor
of the of the lab test and i told him he
should write a book about his his
experience because i thought it was very
educational for anybody who's pursuing
clinical research and i already
developed a name for the um
for the book it should be called the
development of ca 125
of mice men and miss mcdonald and i
think as the story unfolds
you'll understand why so i'm going to
start the story off with this man
um this is my mentor dr robert c knapp
um some of you may know him he was the
former director of gynecology and
gynecologic oncology at the brigham and
women's hospital
and the dana-farber institute in boston
as i mentioned he was a co-inventor of
ca125
i had the pleasure of meeting him as i
was interviewing to return to
while cornell during oncology back in
2006 and he was a visiting scholar
at the medical school his story at least
with regard to ca125 actually begins in
1970
when dr knapp was recruited to harvard
by dr manny friedman
and he actually went into the department
of radiation therapy
dr knapp was very interested in
developing immunotherapy for ovarian
cancer
and i know a lot of people think of
immunotherapy as a novel
uh idea but clearly people have been
trying to use immunotherapy to fight
cancers for many many years
dr knapp included as one might expect in
order to
develop uh treatments against ovarian
cancer you need a
a really good mouse or animal model of
the disease
and one of his first um discoveries
really was this
ovarian cancer model in the c3 atb
fej mouse um dr knapp speaks
very very fondly of this rodent and he
actually attributes this mouse
to getting tenure at harvard um so he
gets there in 1970
and he's developing a mouse model and
he's really interested in looking at
the natural history of ovarian cancer in
fact this mouse when transplanted with
human ovarian cancers actually develops
a disease very
similar to what you see in humans
assignees
lymphatic spread and he's answering a
lot of the questions of how this cancer
spreads throughout the body
through this mouse model like any group
you really need a critical mass
and things start moving along much
faster once he
recruits this man dr robert bast and
many of you know him because dr
bass is such a well-known uh
name in cancer research he's the chair
for cancer research at the university of
texas md anderson
cancer center but back in the 70s he was
doing a fellowship in medical oncology
at the
what was called the sydney farber cancer
institute at the time
and he also was interested in
immunotherapy
and had done a fellowship at the nih in
in leukemia
but when he graduated fellowship he
joined the lab of dr knapp
and brought his experience with
immunotherapy
immunology to his lab
dr knapp and dr bast had a good working
relationship dr
knapp was very clinically active and was
still operating bringing
clinical samples back to the lab dr bass
was in the lab
really trying to develop uh what they
were trying to develop was a silver
bullet a
monoclonal antibody or at least
something they could attach
either radiation therapy or chemotherapy
that would go directly to cancer cells
and kill them but unfortunately
monoclonal antibody
technology had not yet reached uh
harvard
and a serendipitous thing happened was
that
dr knapp was invited by this gentleman
sir john stalworthy
to visit oxford um john stalworthy was a
new zealand-born british obstetrician
had been twice the president of the
royal society of medicine
their common interest was studying the
way cancer
spread through the lymphatic system dr
stallworthy was interested in
cervical cancer and nodal metastasis
dr knapp and ovarian cancer but he
invited him to to oxford
now this is a serendipitous part of the
story is that dr nat's wife
was raised in europe and his
mother-in-law
asked the favor of him before he went
she said while you're there in oxford
could you please go visit the milstein
boy
well it turned out the milstein boy was
cesar milstein it was the son of a
family friend
whose family had moved to argentina from
europe and
milstein and the german cell biologist
george kohler had invented what's called
hybridoma technology while working at
cambridge
and what a hybridoma is is if you
combine the v lymphocyte which
makes antibodies and a myeloma cell
i'm sorry uh a myeloma cell which
produces
uh uh which is in is lives in perpetuity
you'd end up having a way for making a
specific monoclonal
monoclonal antibody in perpetuity it's a
a bit of a factory for a monoclonal
antibody
and as you all know monoclonal
antibodies have revolutionized not only
the treatment but the diagnosis of
diseases and these two gentlemen
won the nobel prize in 1984 for their
work
dr knapp has been looking for something
like this to bring
um to the forefront for ovarian cancer
treatment so both he and dr bass both
traveled to cambridge at different
points to study with dr milstein and
brought the technology back
to boston as i mentioned dr knapp is
still operating
bringing clinical specimens back to the
lab dr
uh basta is trying to develop a
monoclonal antibody against ovarian
cancer
and this is a story of persistence
because it didn't work with the
many of the first attempts but
eventually
in 1981 they published their first paper
showing reactivity of a monoclonal
antibody against human ovarian carcinoma
and what they had developed was a
monoclonal antibody that
identified a portion of a glycoprotein
called muco16
which is on the surface mainly of serous
carcinomas and
for those who don't treat ovarian cancer
the majority of epithelial ovarian
cancers
are a type called cirrus cancer and
when they work with this monoclonal
antibody and
tested it what they found was that all
six of the ovarian cancer cell lines
that they had
in their lab reacted with this
monoclonal antibody
as well as 12 or 20 of the cryopreserved
ovarian cancer tumor specimens
but when they looked at non-ovarian
cancer cell lines like
melanoma cervical cancers only one of 14
non-ovarian cancer cell lines reacted
with it so it seemed on the surface
to be pretty specific for ovarian cancer
it did not react with normal adult or
fetal ovarian tissue
or a variety of other benign tissues it
got its name
ca125 because it's a carbohydrate
antigen it's a glycoprotein
but it was their 125th attempt at
developing a monoclonal antibody and
that's why the name
ca125 so it's a story of
persistence uh in there as well
you may wonder where does miss mcdonald
come into this picture
and to find her you have to look into
the materials and methods of that first
publication on the monoclonal antibody
under preparation and screening of
hybridomas
they mentioned that to produce this
monoclonal immunoglobulin
they immunized balb mice with an
epithelial cell line
which they called ovca 433 which was
established from a patient
em with serous papillary cyst
adenocarcinoma
and that patient was uh was the patient
that i'm mentioning miss mcdonald
and dr knapp still remembers this
patient uh very vividly
and it's just an interesting story where
for some reason her cancer was the one
that established this
monoclonal antibody where so many others
had not
and in fact all the radioamino assays
for ca125 that are still performed today
use the monoclonal antibody that was
developed from miss mcdonald's
cancer it reminds me somewhat of the
story of henrietta lacks
whose cervical cancer cells went on to
establish the hela cell line
um so there are times when patients have
specific cancers that are special in
some way that really
add to research and and push medicine
forward
and so many of us don't know their names
but i'm sure there are other stories of
henrietta lacks and miss mcdonald's out
there
as i mentioned before dr knapp and dr
bass wanted to use
this monoclonal antibody as a magic
bullet and that was their
first intention and they used their
mouse model and tried
many different experiments with varying
success trying to use this for
immunotherapy
but it was really the collaboration with
a doctor named dr zyrowski
from a company called centicore that
turned it from being a therapeutic idea
to a diagnostic idea
dr zyrowski said well why don't you use
that
monoclonal antibody to develop a
radioimmunoassay blood test
maybe if you can measure the amount of
this ca125
and the blood of patients it may have
some clinical utility
and so they developed this
radioimmunoassay and
oc125 was the monoclonal antibody used
the name of that test was ca125
and it is the backbone of the test we
use today
one of the first studies um and and
probably
the most impactful at this point was
published uh
on using this radio immunoassay as a
monitor for the course of epithelial
ovarian cancer
and in this case they had 38 women with
ovarian cancers that they followed
throughout their treatment
and they got serial levels of ca125 and
what they found was that
i'm sorry i should first mention how
they came up with the cutoff of
of abnormal levels
they uh were able to get their hands on
a number of samples
888 samples came from the southeastern
blood center
in milwaukee these were apparently
healthy mouth men and women
they got another 200 blood samples from
the nih
these were um 200 samples from patients
with non-gynecologic malignancies
and 143 samples from patients with
non-malignant diseases
and they have their own serum data serum
sample based at
dana farber of 101 serum samples of
women with ovarian cancer
and putting all these together what they
found was that
if you use the cutoff of 35 units per
mil only one percent of healthy
donors had a level of c125 above this
and that's how the cut off
um became 35 for that initial asset
but when you looked at the women who had
ovarian cancer
88 out of 101 women with ovarian cancer
had
ca125 levels that were greater than 35
units per ml that established that
cutoff
when they looked to monitor the course
of ovarian cancer what they found was
that
if you consider a halving or a doubling
of the ca125 level as evidence of
regression
or progression if it decreased
they found that the vast majority of
patients had clinical evidence of
uh regression of their disease if it
remains stable
less than halving or less than doubling
the majority of patients had stable
disease
on clinical evaluation and if your ca
125 was in fact doubling
that all the patients have progression
of their disease
and so in this early study what they
found was
what is still the most useful um
uh most impactful use for c125 is
monitoring the course
of women who have ovarian cancer to see
how they responded to therapy
but you can imagine their excitement
because now armed with this test it
really opened up
all these potential uses for serum ca125
tests
they knew it monitored response to
ovarian cancer treatment but
perhaps it could be used for screening
of asymptomatic women for early
detection of ovarian cancer
this is a disease that has often very
vague and non-specific
symptoms so that's a great uh thing if
you can develop one
it could be potentially used for the
surveillance of women who had been
treated
for ovarian cancer for the early
detection of the currents
and it could potentially be used for
what i'm here to talk about today which
is the pre-operative evaluation of women
who
present with a suspicious pelvic mass
well the problem with ovarian cystic
masses is they're so
common and yet so few of them are
cancers
annually in the united states there's
millions of ovarian cystic tumors but
only about 22 000 ovarian cancers
diagnosed
and if you combine the data from the
university of kentucky ovarian cancer
screening trial with the
census data from around the same time
what you find is that there are about 90
million american women from
age 13 to 50 and the university of
kentucky screening trial says about 14
of them will get assist per year that's
13 million women
and there's a prevalence about 30
percent of women in that age group with
cysts
so that's about 27 million
pre-menopausal women at any time with an
ovarian cyst
for postmenopausal women using greater
than age 50 there's about 30 million
women in this group
about five percent will get a cyst for a
year that's 1.5 million
women and about 16 percent have assisted
at any given time
so as you can see there are millions of
women with cysts and yet
we're really trying to pick out a needle
in a haystack to figure out which ones
are cancer
now you may ask well why is it so
important to know who has
cancer and i think one of the obvious
reasons is that
it really it really uh
helps to be in the hands of a g-1
oncologist for your care
and i'm going to share some data with
you myself as a general oncologist
i'm well aware of these benefits one of
the first benefits
is if you can imagine a lot of these
women are presenting with just the mass
on their ovary
and ovarian cancer is a tumor that can
spread
uh lymphatically or through the
peritoneal cavity
and have no obvious signs of spread you
have to surgically stage that patient to
determine
who's stage one two or three and that
staging
determines who's going to get adjective
therapy in the form of chemotherapy so
going to a doctor who doesn't completely
stage you misses an opportunity for
a potential life-saving adjuvant
chemotherapy
and this study by mcgowan in 1985 just
really showed this well 291 patients in
this study with early stage ovarian
cancer
and they looked to see how often were
they completely staged
complete staging for ovarian cancer
involves not just the removal of the
uterus
and the tubes and ovaries but sampling
of the pelvic and periodic lymph nodes
biopsies of the intraperitoneal surfaces
97
of gynecologic oncologists completely
surgically staged
only 52 of general obstetrician
gynecologists
but they even did better than general
surgeons who completely staged only 35
of the patients in this study now the
real test
is the impact on survival
and there are a number of studies
showing this but i'm going to present
these two
one is the utah cancer registry which
looked at a large number of women
um with over new ovarian cancers between
1992 and 1998
one of the saddest things that this
study showed is that the majority of
women with ovarian cancer in this
country are not treated by
general oncologists and in this study
only 39
were ever seen by a g1 oncologist but
for those women who were careful by a
g-1 oncologist those with advanced
disease had a significant survival
advantage
the median survival for those patients
was 26 months
versus 15 months for those who had not
been cared for
by a g-1 oncologist and the second study
the guided meta-analysis
is a is a meta-analysis of 18 studies
and it showed the same thing there was a
marked benefit
for having a g1 oncologist involved in
your care
oncologists did more complete surgical
staging for early stage disease
they were more aggressive surgically for
those with advanced disease and
were able to achieve what we call an
optimal side of reduction
meaning they had all their metastatic
tumor removed at a higher rate
um and you saw improved median and
overall survival
so it's critical to get these patients
with a suspicious adenoxyl mass
into the right hands for these survival
reasons
but what are the tools that any doctor
has at their hands to determine whether
a mass
on an ovary is benign or malignant you
have physical exam
that would be a pelvic exam an abdominal
exam and a lymph node survey
you've got imaging modalities like
sonogram mri
cat scans and i want to focus on serum
biomarkers or algorithms
that combine biomarkers with menopausal
status
so let's start with ca125 as you know it
i mentioned
in this dr knapp's early study it was
expressed in 80
of the ovarian cancers in their initial
trial but the thing you have to pay
attention to is that
the majority of patients with ovarian
cancer because of
non-specific symptoms and because of the
lack of a
effective screen present with advanced
stage disease
um so it was uh elevated in the majority
patients advanced stage disease but
again it was also limited by cell type
uh ca125 is most highly expressed in
serous tumors which are the majority
but poorly expressed in other
non-service types like ovarian useless
tumors
clear cell undifferentiated and
sarcomatic malignancies
where juice is limited um
where we really want to pick up these
cases where we think we have the biggest
impact
on survival is early stage and early
studies by bass and
jacobs also show that it's limited there
as well
ca125 is elevated only half of women
with early stage ovarian cancer
so again it's it's approved for
monitoring
um clear for monitoring for recurrence
or progression of ovarian cancer in this
country
but it's not clear to evaluate ovarian
masses prior to surgery
despite that being a very common use of
the test
this study by maucasian and dr knapp's
group in 1988
showed some of the limitations of state
125 here
in this study they had 158 women with
pelvic masses who were scheduled for
surgery
90 ended up being benign 68 had
malignancy
and they used actually a co 125 cutoff
of 65
um to determine whether they thought it
was benign or malignant
and that cut was significant in only
eight percent of benign patients
and 75 of malignant masses and so
ca125 had a 91 sensitivity for detecting
cancer
and a positive predictive value for
postmenopausal women
which which was pretty high it was 98
but you see some of the weakness when
you look at the pre-menopause of women
where there was only a 49 positive
predictive value
meaning that if your test was abnormal
you actually had the disease and
then this is because predictive values
are impacted by prevalence of cancer in
that
population and the prevalence of cancer
in the post-menopausal one was 63
but only 15 in the pre-menopause of
women
so this highlights one of the
limitations of c125 in that it is not
very specific for ovarian cancer there
are a number of gynecologic
and non-gynecologic conditions that can
elevate your ca125
in fact for the gynecologic condition
some of them are very very common things
like uterine
fibroids adenomyosis endometriosis
infections um non-gynecologic things
like
congestive heart failure uh liver and
kidney disease can do it so
um it is hampered by this lack of
specificity
so what kind of guidance do we have for
when a
general ob gyn should send the patient
within that nexul mass
to a general oncologist for that we do
have some recommendations by the
american congress of
status and gynecology um and
there's practice bulletin 174 which was
just updated in november of 2016
and it outlines referral criteria for
women with that nexo masses when they
should be sent on to a g-1 oncologist
if you see for post-menopausal women a
ca125
greater than 35 is an indication to send
that patient to
a g-1 oncologist because of its high
positive predictive value
now other findings such as the sono
that's very suggestive of malignancy or
obvious evidence of metastatic disease
clearly those patients should be going
on to an oncologist
but look at the pre-menopause of women
where we see the vast majority of
ednextal masses will
occur in this country there is no
specific cutoff of c125 that should send
the patient to a g1 oncologist in fact
the most recent update just says a very
elevated ca125
in the 2007 bulletin they had chosen 200
as a cutoff of c125 that that was based
on largely
um expert opinion and not really well
designed studies
and so we have this guidance where if
you post menopausal with any elevation
of c125
you go to a g1 oncologist at least
according to eckhart criteria
but if you're pre-menopausal it has to
be just quote-unquote very elevated
both um premenopausal and postmenopausal
women
i should mention that you see on this
slide the last
element on the recommendations is an
elevated score
on a formal risk assessment test
and let's go through what is a formal
risk assessment test
well there are three fda cleared formal
risk assessment
scoring tests there's the risk of
malignancy algorithm
there's what's called the multivariate
index assay
or over one and now there's a second
generation
multivariate index assay overall and i
want to go through each
three of those to show you what they're
made of
and how they perform in this setting
so to start off the conversation on
he4 i'm sorry i'm roma i have to tell
you about this novel
tuna marker human epididymis iv
um he4 was first identified as a
specific protein in the human epididymis
in 1991 and then shown to be
overexpressed in ovarian cancer in 1999.
it was shown to be a biomarker as a
serum test in ovarian cancer by
hellstrom in 2002
not a lot known about he4 is normal
function
it's a and glycosylated protein it's
thought to have some
anti-protease activity although the
target protease is not identified
it's thought to play some role in sperm
maturation and the normal
epididymis and place some sort of
anti-inflammatory response to cancer
development
one of the benefits of he4 though is its
distribution of expression and ovarian
cancer where ca125 is mainly expressed
in serous ovarian cancer what you see is
that
at4 antigen is highly expressed in
serous endometrioid and clear cell
ovarian cancer
but like co 125 is rarely expressed in
mucinous germ cell
or sex court ovarian cancer tumors so
you have a wider spectrum
of expression in ovarian cancer
so he4 is used along with ca125 and a
woman's
menopausal status to determine what's
called the risk of malignancy algorithm
and this is a algorithm that has been
published you can
get calculators online that will do this
calculation for you
but the predictive index is different
whether you're pre-menopause a woman or
a postmenopausal woman for
for premenopausal woman the pi is minus
12
plus 2.38 times the natural log of 84
plus 0.0626
times the natural log of ca125 and in
postmenopausal women is minus 8.09 plus
1.04 times the natural log of 84
plus 0.732 times natural log of ca 125
and i'm telling you the the formulas
because what i want you to notice is
that
in pre-menopausal women you see the
impact of ca 125 being brought down
by this .06 coefficient in front of it
whereas in the post-menopausal woman you
see a 0.7
in front of the natural log of c125 and
it shows you that
um the risk of a malignancy algorithm is
is leveraging the impact of ca 125's
uh performance and postmenopausal women
and he forced performance
in pre-menopausal women the roma
is the exponential of the pi over one
plus the exponent
of the p i times ten and that gives you
an odds ratio
and there's a cut off that says this
patient is high risk
a low risk for this ed nexo mass being a
cancer
based on these three things ca125
he4 and menopausal status
this test roma was validated in two
different studies
one was a study that was conducted
mainly with gyne oncologists
and it was a high likelihood cohort
because the cancer incidence
as you would expect in the hands of
oncologists was higher it's 24
and a second study in a low likelihood
cohort that was carried out in 13
tertiary care and community sites
um where the cancer incidence was only
10
what's interesting if you look at the
roma performance in the high-risk
population
it's exciting to see that in patients
who was stage one and two
it correctly identified 30 out of 35 of
the cases
or 86 if you remember what i mentioned
about ca125
only 50 of of patients with stage one or
two
ovarian cancer have elevated c125 so
roma is a huge improvement for early
stage detection
uh compared to say 125 alone and for
advanced stages
it picked up 99 of cases uh correctly
identified
and so if you look at all invasive
epithelial ovarian cancers
you see about a 94 sensitivity
with roma
in the low-risk population you see
similar numbers there the
detection rate was about 93.8 similar to
the high risk
um what's important to know here is that
the specificity
was fixed at 75 to achieve that
sensitivity in both pre and
postmenopausal women
so the low specificity of
ca 125 and premenopausal women can be
overcome
using uh roma
and that this model can be used to
effectively triage patients
to symptoms of excellence for all the
reasons that i mentioned earlier
now it's important to notice that the
fda
clearance for roma is for a woman who's
greater than 18 years of age
in which you you've already decided
you're going to operate on this ovarian
cyst
it's not a test that's meant to tell you
whether or not to operate on a cyst
it's a test that tells you should you be
doing that surgery
if you're a general obstetrician
gynecologist or should you be referring
that patient on
to a gynecologic oncologist in 2011 dr
knapp and i
um did a subset analysis of these
these two cohorts and we were looking to
see how uh
he 4 um did just in premenopausal women
um because we believe that's where our
true value added
and it was an interesting finding we we
had 229 pre-menopause of women we've had
nexum masses
the majority being benign 85 but 8
of them had epithelial ovarian cancer
and 7 had borderline
ovarian tumors the ca125 sensitivity
was 83 percent and the fifth and the
specificity was 59
but he 4 had a higher sensitivity of
88.9
and what we were really interested in
was the specificity it was 91.8
and what we found is if you were
pre-menopausal women in this study said
if you had a uh elevated um
if you had a normal he4 regardless of
what you say 125
said it ruled out cancer in 98
of the patients so even if you had an
elevated c125 a normal he4 could be used
to further risk stratify
over one is a similar test it's it's
uh where roma has just two analytes oval
one
um is is made up of five
different serum tests um that's
transtheratin
april lipoprotein a1 beta2 microglobulin
transferrin and ca125
so um it is also fda cleared for women
greater than 18 years of age with
in uh at nexon master whom surgery is
also indicated so it's not again to tell
you who to operate on and who not to
operate on
it's a triage tool
in the oval one registration trial it
was a large study with 590 women greater
than 18 years of age
came from 27 primary care and specialty
sites
and they correlated the overwhelm
results with physician assessment and
pathology results
now the algorithm that overwhelm uses to
calculate the risk stratification is not
published it's proprietary
so you don't know exactly the results of
any individual
analyte in the test they had 161
malignancies identified 27
uh were cancers similar to aroma there
was a 93
sensitivity but the specificity was 43
um the positive predicted value was 42
and a negative predicted value of 92
so similar sensitivity in the original
registration trial
slightly lower uh lower specificity
um but they were able to show that it
did improve physician assessment
for both gui nouns and non-gynox that
over one was able to pick up cases that
were read as
likely benign by physician assessment
and were actually cancers
overwhelm was validated in a large study
a prospective multi-institutional study
that compared over 1 in ca125 and
clinical
impression slightly lower incidence of
cancer in this population
18.6 but over one sensitivity for all
ovarian malignancies again performed
well 95
sensitive um it correctly classified 83
of cancers missed by clinical impression
and 70 percent missed by ca125
and it predicted benign disease and 50
when combined with clinical impression
the specificity again was slightly lower
than what we saw with roma
at 54 and a positive predictive value of
31
and concerns about the low specificity
of over one led to the second generation
of the uh multivariate uh
uh study and this is called over
or over two and in overall what happens
is they replace transtheratin
with he4 and beta2 macroglobulin with
fsh
and the goal is to increase the
specificity and the positive predictive
value while maintaining the excellent
sensitivity
and negative predictive value that had
already been established
where roma uses two different
calculations for
pre-menopausal and postmenopausal the
fact that follicle stimulating hormone
is in over two o'vera it removes the
need to include menopausal status
because that will control for menopausal
status
um the validation study of ovary used a
bank serum sample
from a prospective court of 493 women
undergoing
surgery for a nexul mass 18 percent had
cancer
when they combined overall with
physician assessment the sensitivity
remained excellent at 94
but the specificity was increased to 69
if you remember it was only 54 for over
one so this was a significant
improvement
um and the overa positive predictive
value increased to 40
whereas over one was 40 was 31
so this is a improvement over the first
generation
of mia
and gives excellent sensitivity and
specificity
so accurate triage of invasive ovarian
cancer patients
to appropriately train clinicians is
associated with improved outcomes i
showed you data on comprehensive staging
improved surgical debulking and
ultimately better
survival and while ca125 is effective
for modern response to ovarian cancer
treatment as shown in dr knapp's early
studies
it has limited sensitivity and
specificity for the detection of
malignancy in women presenting
within that nexul mass one of the
reasons why
it is not clear for this indication but
we have
we we have better tests now we have roma
over one
and overa all three fda clear tests that
can increase the detection of malignancy
preoperatively
and allow appropriate triage to
gynecologic oncologists
and thereby giving the patients this
improved survival associated with their
care
so i'd like to thank you for your
attention um
this picture is taken at dr knapp's 90th
birthday
uh celebration where my wife and i met
with he
and his friend and um had a wonderful
dinner together
so i appreciate the opportunity to talk
to you about serum biomarkers and
ovarian cancer
and give you a bit of the history and
the development of ca125
i'd like to open the floor to any
questions
thank you dr holcomb for that
outstanding presentation
we will now move into the live q a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q a box
now let's get started our first question
is
are formal cancer risk assessment tools
widely utilized
by general gynecologists when managing
adnexal masses
you know i i wish i could say yes that
they are but
um and i'm sure there's some regional
differences and i have to admit i i
practice in the northeast and and may be
different in other parts of the country
but i can say
uh my clinical experience is that
they're underutilized
um i think many people many general
obgyns are trained that ca125 is the
go-to test in this situation
and um and may not be aware of the
limitations of ca 125 whereas patients
are
uh and and i should mention that it's
it's
really leading to decisions not just on
triage who should be doing a surgery but
how um how important is for the surgeon
to
be performed in the first place for
example someone may have
a fairly suspicious at nexul mass
and their practitioner is relieved by a
normal
ca125 and they'll say well uh you know
the patient doesn't want surgery
maybe we can just follow this where the
gut was telling them
based on morphology on the imaging and
yet they are
uh relieved and the converse i've seen
i've seen patients with a
a simple cyst that has very little risk
of malignancy
and the woman may have a history of
endometriosis or a history of fibroids
and there's other reasons why her ca125
will be elevated
and because of an elevated ca125 there
will be recommended
surgery um so i think uh
you know they're underutilized i a lot
of patients as you saw from the utah
registry study
um are diagnosed with ovarian cancer and
never having a g1 oncologist
involved in their care so i think you
know it really is a
um a responsibility of g1 oncologists
and
you know the medical community to sort
of get this information out
to doctors that there are tests that do
much better than ca125 alone
and and really explain to them the way
it should be used
so our next question is going to be
where do we stand with the development
of an effective ovarian cancer screening
test
so you know i i that's the holy grail of
ovarian cancer i mean we're talking
about a disease that has
uh at least epithelial ovarian cancer
such bad survival because it's
it's advanced stage for the majority
patients when we pick it up and
you know there have been a number of
trials that have used ca 125
as a straight cut off of 35 and that
being a trigger to do with sonogram
and i think it's fair to say that that
type of screening
while it can pick up ovarian cancer
cases has not been proven
to um decrease mortality of the disease
there was a study in the united kingdom
that was published a couple of years ago
where they used the same
tools but in a different way they used
the
small changes in ca 125 that occurred
from year to year
to determine the risk of cancer and let
that be the
uh the trigger for sonograms and and
there is some evidence that after
multiple cycles of screening there may
be some improvement
in in mortality associated with that
screening
but overall i say the search for that
that uh
holy grail is still continuing and
there's a lot of really
innovative things that people are doing
um a lot of attention being paid to
what's called proximate fluids
where people are testing not the blood
but
uh fluid in the fallopian tubes uh or in
the uterine cavity
i've seen studies where they're actually
implant sensors in those areas to give
real-time
data on multiple analytes um so
a lot of work still going on but it's an
elusive goal this
uh effective screen
and dr holcomb it looks like we have
time for one more question
have there been substantial advances in
the treatment of ovarian cancer
um i'd have to say yes um and i know a
lot of people say we're not winning the
battle on cancer and i think if you look
at
a endpoint like 10-year survival
in ovarian cancer you would see some
stagnation
but when i looked at for example the
universe
the utah registry study where g1
oncologists being involved in your care
gave you an improvement of survival and
those patients only had 26 months
medium survival you know we don't see
that nowadays we're seeing
you know patients live four years five
years
and some of it is aggressive uh surgical
technique
but i think even more so it's having
more therapeutic options
medical therapeutic options and probably
the biggest
impact i've seen is the introduction of
park inhibitors
park inhibitors as maintenance therapy
and it's just one of those therapies it
seems that the
earlier you move it into a woman's care
with ovarian cancer
the bigger the impact and uh just
recently there have been a number of
studies where they were using parp
inhibitors as maintenance therapy
after someone goes into their first
remission and finding
years of improvement in progression-free
survival
which i'm sure will have huge impacts on
overall survival
as that data matures so you know i'd
have to say yes um
i'm optimistic that we are seeing
improvements
thank you again dr kevin holcomb and
thank you to the audience
for your outstanding questions we hope
you found today's presentation to be
informative
and insightful this presentation will be
available for on-demand viewing
don't miss out on other valuable
presentations on our agenda
please visit the agenda tab in the
auditorium for a full listing
thank you again for your participation
and until next time
goodbye you